because there's no plot why would i
watch that
what is plot
great question plot is conflict
um
so
we need the character first i i for me i
always need the character first
sometimes though i do come up with a
with a situation first
and plot's kind of a situation but we do
have to put the character in the
situation
so
we put a character in a situation and
the character has a goal
and you go great the character has a
goal
and then the character moves forward to
that goal and we throw obstacles at that
character and that's plot how is the
character going to
move through those obstacles will they
will they make the right or wrong
decision will they learn from that
decision
that's that's essentially what plot is
to me is
throwing obstacles at the character
may and then seeing how they get out of
them
for better or for worse and then how
they move on to the next scene so that's
when uh
that's that's that's when the beauty of
creating the plot and essentially
creating the three-act structure that
kind of turns into this huge showdown at
the end but we need to know how the
character gets in and out of obstacles
throughout the whole
uh movie and then that's when that's
that's adding to the plot and it's all
pointing to
one direction when we get to that
when we get to that showdown so
how would you teach plot right now if if
i'm a new student in the class and i
don't know what that is
um sure like a sort of a
reader's digest version of
i i like to come up with i like to come
up with um really lame
like the lamest situation like i'll say
so let's say your character uh wants a
wants to buy gum
okay great that's you know any cause any
any goal
as long as the character's totally
invested in the goal makes sense
so
the character wants to rule all of the
world
great if the character wants a stick of
gum
great but but it needs to mean
just as much to that character to get
that stick of gum so let's get them a
stick of gum great the store's across
the street now
um as your character watch walks to get
that stick of gum
what can you do to make it harder for
them to get that stick of gum and then i
throw it to my students and it's just
like let's just be absurd let's be
totally absurd what would you do i get a
baseball bat and i knock them in the
knees great knock them in the knees beat
those beat those kneecaps out but that
character still needs that gum and we're
gonna love that character for using his
elbows to try to get to that store to
get to the gum what can we do next and
so we can create a um we're creating
plot
by just throwing essentially uh
you know rocks at this character who
wants something so bad
um and it's so that's where there's a
lot of fun
i have a lot of fun discussing plot with
my students because it's just like let's
come up with the silliest scenarios and
then great now when you go to your scene
where the woman wants the wants the man
to ask her on a date but she's not sure
what he thinks of him
the stakes are just as high as if
someone wants a piece of gum or someone
wants to be the ruler of the world
now what are the obstacles you're going
to put in and then when
they have a character worksheet they
know the flaws and the strengths of
their characters then they know how to
like bring all of that in heighten it
beyond belief
and then we we're gonna watch that scene
and be like
is he gonna ask her out or not
uh so that's essentially plot to me
okay and then should i be writing this
like sidebar thing that no one's going
to see
that i'm going to know about the
convenience store clerk
and that's going to help set up the
maybe the tension in the scene so our
protagonist is gonna run in
and they're gonna fumble for change for
this gum
and there's gonna be something about
this clerk
that's gonna now add new conflict
maybe that clerk used to be a ceo and
they were like go and and and this is a
job they got and
they remember this person because that
was one of their employees
and now
i mean i mean so but but necessarily the
or the the audience won't know that i
have all this backstory but there's
going to be a tension there
yeah and as long as i i feel like as
long as
the story stays on the protagonist who
wants the gum and then this is another
this is another obstacle so they
actually make it to the store after
all of my all of my students have thrown
in all their uh you know we're gonna
take out his tongue and his teeth he
won't be able to chew gum okay what are
we gonna do there
um
and then yeah you add even more
attention when we get to the store we
can have we can have another
antagonist of sorts
uh blocking
the actual getting of the gum or
or that that maybe we maybe
the protagonist gets a helper maybe the
clerk is a helper in the situation and
then we and um because our you know our
heroes do need helpers along the way
and then
um but then we'll lose that helper but
it's and that's when we have the
victories and the losses if we give too
much losses if we're throwing too much
loss at a character then um
then we'll lose our audience
but we get that character that victory
is like oh the gum great what's next um
that's what we we need to ask the
question
what's next and we also need to give
them we need to give them a moment to
breathe and go
ah we got the gum
you know and then uh i don't know where
to go from there and because that's such
a simplistic story but
that's yeah that's the victories and
losses and when i work with my students
when they do their beat sheets i try to
i'm like note where the victories are
nowhere note where your breaths are
because you need to give your character
uh
oh all right i got this and but that's
the last thing they got because the next
thing's coming up and going to hit them
even harder it's like
fix that and then boom next so
so do you find a lot of writers maybe
they're more intermediate they're
they're not letting it breathe enough
they know hey i need conflict and i need
it by this point
but
now they're they're infusing too much
conflict
i it's bet i think it's better to have
more conflict than less because it's
it's it's a lot of fun to throw the
conflict in there and then pull it out
and go that's too much that's too much
um where
uh
yeah and and sometimes people ask it
feels so manufactured and i'm like it is
manufactured you know it feels fake it
is fake
it's it's just like it this isn't this
isn't real life with this
go ahead and feel awkward about it not
feeling real because
you just keep crafting and crafting it
and in the world of and the building the
world of and this is one you know people
talk about world building and science
fiction movies or other things there's
world building and romantic comedies
there's world building in every single
movie
so build that world stay in the confines
of the world and then um
yeah and let them run let the what the
characters run right because if you want
to go to you know mystic pizza or a
pretty woman or whatever i mean there
was world building and all that you have
a small new england town this restaurant
you got is it conchita farrell she was
like there she ran the restaurant and
it's you know it's kind of a fun
atmosphere but it's no nonsense and and
that they're waiting for this food
critic to come in that they're all
terrified of that's gonna either make or
break the restaurant so you know they're
getting ready for the shift they're
polishing whatever um and so now we feel
like okay i'm in this small town i know
that this restaurant means everything to
this owner and and
you know they're when the food critic
comes in they're all smiles and it's
probably overly you know they're giving
too much attention yeah so
um i'm not even sure where i'm going
with that i think i just explained all
of mystic pizzas sorry right one and i
still need to watch it actually i feel
bad please i need to watch it but
but you said it you said exactly the
thing
um
it's it's the um it's everything they
want it's their whole
their character we don't need to know
that they have these other wants in
their lives you know are they sexually
satisfied in this relationship that
we're not seeing off screen who cares we
need to know that that restaurant critic
coming in is the most important piece of
their life
sure sure and there might be a little
bit of that in mystic pizza too oh is
there oh cool
yeah you'll have to start
what do you say to writers who tell you
that plot doesn't matter there are
writers who say plot doesn't matter
there might be
i think
well i i was thinking what you asked me
like think of some movies that meant
everything to you
uh in one of our email exchanges and i
was thinking of stranger than paradise
the jim jarmusch film
and um
and the reason that meant everything to
me is because i saw it when i was a kid
on the pbs
affiliate in san francisco channel 9. 3d
yes for some odd reason they wat they
showed it over and over again they said
this is only 67 takes and blah blah blah
but
it made me realize that a movie is a
craft and not just
that's when i kind of that's when i got
the separation went oh wow
and like a movie like that seems
plotless and a lot of it is plotless to
an extent
or is it
i'm i'm am i thinking of the one where
they had they opened with the two elvis
enthusiasts on the train the gym germany
that's a mystery train oh okay because i
love that one too yeah and then they go
in this hotel and okay right
now that's a lot more that is a lot more
plot this is the one with uh john lurie
and um
[Music]
where they're just his hungarian cousin
comes to stay with him in uh brooklyn
and it's uh
yeah it's like there's plot in there so
i it's um i like what what film wouldn't
have
can you think of a film that doesn't
have plot okay i know i'm not supposed
to use this reference dinner with andre
my dinner with andre does that have plot
i haven't seen it you haven't seen it
okay well there it
is until i can't use that reference
anymore but i think that but i think i i
know the
you know i know the actors in it and i
remember seeing clips of it
they do want something that's true and
if they want something
do they get it are they are they are
they having a conversation where they
um
where they shift
the um
where they shift the idea in the other
person's mind
uh where the other person has a
oh i didn't think of it that way moment
um
or are they just kind of coming at each
other with this is me this is me this is
me this is me
um so yeah well that's why i haven't
seen my dinner with andre because
there's no plot why would i watch that
apparently it did very well but uh but
i'm just thinking that i'm just thinking
of that from from a long time ago but
yeah it's i mean and that's just it's
it's hard to come up with an example of
a movie that doesn't really have plot
even if it's yeah you know i love
i love slow scandinavian films i love
there's this author t singer that i read
his books and they're about nothing
and it just it brings me absolute joy
and the plot is like a little bit um
there's even there's even youtube
channels that show norwegian trains just
going from oslo to bergen
and i'll watch it and
so it's
it might be there's no plot there but
there is forward momentum there's no
obstacles
but there's forward momentum
um so maybe that's maybe that's the um
[Music]
an example of a reason not to have plot
uh
i you know where
yeah i'll watch something but i think i
watch it more for artistic reasons than
i do for like oh my god i can't wait
till they i can't wait till they get to
you know
uh stavong or yes no i barely care so it
i think i think i don't care but i enjoy
if that makes sense yeah there's great
uh norwegian or scandinavian in general
youtube channels where they talk about
you know different christmas uh you know
customs and things like that and they
are really fascinating to watch how they
put it together yeah it's very artistic
no i could watch dolphins just go in and
out of the water for two hours and i'll
be
you know the march of the penguins i
mean
what a beautiful film uh there you know
i if i remember right there is plot to
it because they are
going somewhere to i think it's it's all
about the reproduction and the likes
they have to take so there are very high
stakes in the march of the penguins and
it's presented to us in a
you know kind of a lighthearted way but
um
but there's still stakes there yeah i
think
uh i i would not be interested in
filmmakers who don't
who think that there's no reason for
plot um
that even a photographer has to have
uh a plot you know a photographer is
telling a story they're they're they're
trying to frame a they're trying to
frame a photo
they're they're looking for conflict
they're looking for
they're looking for how
how to present it and it just may you
know then to one person that just like
oh it's a picture of a face but if you
talk to the photographer they'll tell
you
what the um
what the tension is and then so that we
do need tension i think
you